d'octobre 2020 Samuel Paty était
assassiné pour avoir accompli son métier
d'enseignant cet attentat qui a choqué
toute la France à tragiquement mise en
lumière les pressions menaces et
agressions dont peuvent être victimes
les enseignants au quotidien quelques
jours après ce drame nos deux
commissions avait interrogé Gérald
Darmanin et Jean-Michel Blanquer sur les
circonstances ayant abouti à ce meurtre
et les réponses mises en place par
l'Éducation nationale les forces de
sécurité l'institution judiciaire pour y
faire face plus de deux ans après les
fêtes l'émotion reste vive tandis que
les pressions et les menaces exercées
sur les enseignants demeurent plus que
jamais d'actualité afin de faire toute
la lumière sur cette situation nos deux
commissions ont souhaité créer une
mission conjointe de contrôle consacré
au modalités de signalement et de
traitement par les pouvoirs publics des
pressions menaces et agressions subies
par les enseignants et les personnels
personnel de direction des
établissements pour notre première
audition il nous semblait important de
vous entendre monsieur le ministre pour
évoquer plusieurs sujets relevant de vos
compétences nous souhaitons d'abord
objectiver les pressions menaces et
violences recensées dans l'éducation
nationale et comptons sur vous et vos
services non seulement pour connaître le
nombre et la nature des actes commis
chaque année à l'encontre des personnels
enseignants et administratifs mais aussi
pour bien comprendre le révolution nous
souhaitons également savoir comment sont
prises en charge les personnels victimes
d'intimidation de menaces ou d'agression
autrement dit quelle mesure concrètes
ont été mises en place à cet égard
depuis octobre 2020
enfin des sondages réguliers soulignent
le développement à l'armant de
l'autosensure chez les enseignants en
particulier du secondaire dans le cadre
de leur enseignement quelle mesure ont
été prises depuis deux ans et demi afin
d'aider nos professeurs à faire face aux
pressions auxquelles ils sont confrontés
de la part d'élèves ou de parents
d'élèves à l'énoncer de simples
connaissances historiques biologiques ou
philosophique voici Monsieur le Ministre
quelques-unes des questions que nous
aurons sans doute l'occasion d'aborder
au cours de cette audition qui je vous
le rappelle est ouverte à la presse et
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat
nos travaux ayant par ailleurs obtenu du
Sénat de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes je vous rappelle
qu'un faux témoignage serait passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal aussi
monsieur le ministre je vous invite à
traiter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en me disant je le jure je le
jure je vous remercie et je cède la
parole à François de elbifet président
de la commission des lois pour compléter
mon propos
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues quelques mots
en qualité de président de la commission
des lois tout d'abord pour vous
remercier Monsieur le Ministre d'être là
cet après-midi remercier des collègues
d'être présent
la mission que nous menons avec le
président Lafont et nos deux commissions
en réalité réunies
des pouvoirs d'enquête qui nous sont qui
nous ont été donnés par le Bureau du
Sénat pour objectif de travailler sur
les conséquences de l'affaire dont elle
a été victime Samuel Paty notamment en
matière de protection et d'organisation
aujourd'hui des services de l'État pour
accompagner et aider l'ensemble des
professeurs j'allais dire de
l'enseignement secondaire comme
d'ailleurs d'une enseignement
universitaire dans la mission qui est la
leur on a beaucoup on demande beaucoup
d'ailleurs aux enseignants et au chef
d'établissement on leur demande
notamment de former notre jeunesse à
l'esprit critique et la citoyenneté cela
n'a jamais été facile et cela n'est
peut-être encore moins aujourd'hui dès
lors le soutien de la hiérarchie de leur
hiérarchie mais aussi de tout l'appareil
d'État nous paraît absolument essentiel
en complément des questions que le
président de la fond vient de vous poser
je souhaite donc vous interroger pour si
me concerne sur les relations entre
l'institution scolaire
les services de sécurité intérieure
ainsi que les services de justice dans
le cadre de la loi confortant le respect
des principes de la République une
infraction spécifique d'entrave à la
fonction d'enseignants a été créée elle
figure au sein des dispositions de
l'article 431-1 du code pénal par
ailleurs les menaces sont également
réprimées par les dispositions de
l'article 433-5 du même code enfin la
diffusion la diffusion malveillante
d'informations personnelles et désormais
réprimée elle par les dispositions de
l'article 223-1 du code pénal
avez-vous monsieur le ministre disposez
vous d'éléments sur le nombre de
plaintes qui ont été déposés et des
poursuites qu'on peut être engagées sur
ces motifs plus largement les échanges
avec les services de police et de
gendarmes riz et avec les renseignements
généraux
territoriaux aujourd'hui permet-il un
suivi des situations à risque comment se
passe l'accompagnement vers le dépôt de
plainte et la prise en compte des
menaces en cas d'incident enfin comment
jugez-vous vous est-ce qualité dans la
fonction qu'elle a vôtre de ministre la
prise en charge de ces questions par la
justice
la question se pose au niveau des
établissements comme au niveau des
rectorats et cette question
d'articulation des services est
essentielle car on sait que la
définition des priorités communes et
l'échange d'information sont
essentielles à l'inverse on sait qu'à
défaut de ces échanges le risque est que
l'enseignant se retrouve seul renvoyé
d'un service à un autre chacun
évidemment ayant son objectif propre
nous espérons donc que des progrès ont
été accomplis sur ces points bien sûr en
outre les modalités de signalement des
agressions et forment de pression par
des collègues qui en auraient été
témoins méritent également notre
attention en théorie d'ailleurs la visée
de l'article 40 du code de procure pénal
est clair et devrait conduire tout
fonctionnaire témoin d'une agression
dans l'exercice de ces fonctions à
saisir directement le procureur de la
République
en pratique toutefois il semble il
semble je le dis que le recours à ce
mécanisme soit finalement marginal
pouvez-vous nous apporter des précisions
à ce sujet et selon vous comment
pourrions-nous garantir l'effectivité de
ces dispositions
j'en ai terminé mais celui sur cette
série de questions naturellement
d'autres collègues proposeront également
mais je voudrais quand même au nom du
Président Lafont et en mon nom rappelé à
nos collègues la règle suivante le
ministre ne peut pas répondre
sur les faits qui font l'objet d'une
enquête en cours et donc sur
l'organisation de la protection à
laquelle monsieur Samuel Paty avait
droit
notre but ici est de voir quelles
conséquences pratiques ont été tirées de
ce drame pour protéger les enseignants
j'indique que c'est la règle absolue et
nous devons naturellement la respecter
voilà merci monsieur le ministre
Messieurs les Présidents mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je tiens tout
d'abord à vous remercier pour la
création de cette mission d'information
sur un sujet crucial pour les personnels
de l'Éducation nationale ce sont eux qui
font notre école nous leur devons
reconnaissances respects et protection
garantir la protection de nos personnels
c'est la condition sinequanone de
l'exercice de leurs fonctions vous le
savez et l'actualité récente nous le
démontre encore notre époque connaît de
graves menaces sur nos institutions les
empêchant parfois de mener à bien leurs
missions qu'il s'agisse des professeurs
des élus locaux des forces de l'ordre
les menaces et les pressions dont ils
peuvent être l'objet sont des atteintes
directes à notre République et à nos
valeurs
certains drames nous le rappelle
douloureusement et même vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président si la mission ne
porte pas sur l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty et que je ne pourrais pas évoquer
directement cette affaire les procédures
judiciaires étant en cours j'aimerais en
ouverture de mon propos lui rendre
hommage vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président l'émotion reste vive
l'éducation nationale et ses personnels
de son malheureusement pas épargnés par
les multiples formes de violences qui
traversent la société qui dépasse le
seul lieu de l'école terrorisme santé
mental cyber-harcèlement délinquance
c'est pour cela que l'éducation
nationale ne peut agir seul en ces
domaines et que des coopérations
renforcées existent principalement avec
le ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère de la Justice vous
auditionnerez je crois mais deux
collègues ministres qui pourront
également revenir sur le travail qui est
mené en coordination si vous me le
permettez j'organiserai mon propos
liminaire en trois grandes parties les
constats les chiffres vous invitiez
monsieur le Président une rapide
présentation des procédures de
signalement et enfin je terminerai par
quelques pistes de consolidation de nos
procédures le constat tout d'abord
quels sont donc les menaces pression
agressions qui s'exercent à l'encontre
des professeurs et des agents de
l'éducation nationale les professeurs
les personnels de l'Éducation nationale
sont exposées ils l'ont toujours été à
la ville violence que nous pourrions
qualifier d'ordinaire par exemple les
professeurs des écoles subissent parfois
des agressions lorsqu'ils jouent leur
rôle en matière de protection de
l'enfance et signal des situations
d'enfants en danger je pense aussi aux
pressions que subissent certains
professeurs de lycées au sujet des notes
et de leurs conséquences plus ou moins
avérées sur parcoursup
avec le phénomène du cible du
harcèlement entre élèves qui a pris une
ampleur préoccupante dans sa version
cyber et qui dépasse désormais largement
le cadre de l'école les équipes peuvent
être régulièrement menacées ou accusés
de situations de souffrance d'enfants ou
d'adolescents que ces situations
relèvent réellement de harcèlement ou
non nous avons connu récemment un
emballement médiatique et des propos
d'une grande violence notamment à
l'encontre de chefs d'établissement
nous voyons également émerger des
menaces qui émanent de l'extrême droite
le collectif part en vigilant n'hésite
pas à dénoncer sur les réseaux sociaux
ou les médias la propagande LGBT l'étude
de texte immigrationnistes je cite dont
certains professeurs seraient les
responsables parmi les phénomènes
nouveaux il faut enfin ajouter les
violences des élèves parfois gravissimes
comme l'assassinat d'Agnès Lassalle il y
a quelques mois parfois en lien avec des
troubles mentaux des élèves il faut
aussi évoquer les violences que font
subir les parents aux enseignants par
leur menaces de plus en plus fréquentes
et décomplexées par exemple le 22 juin
dernier une mère menaçant de mort une
enseignante pour un pull oublié en
maternelle l'enseignante a déposé
plainte et demander la protection
fonctionnelle
je termine évidemment par des atteintes
aux principes de laïcité lorsqu'elle se
traduisent par le port de tenue
manifestants une appartenance religieuse
ou par des contestations d'enseignement
atteintes qui ont objectivement
augmenter comme les chiffres que le
ministère public tous les mois en
atteste et conduisent à des situations
de tension dans les établissements
parfois des menaces ou des agressions
qui s'exercent à l'encontre des
personnels
comment mesurons-nous ces phénomènes
l'ADEP notre direction des études
statistiques a mis en place deux outils
statistiques pour mesurer et
caractériser les atteintes envers les
personnels l'enquête CIVIS système
d'information de vigilance sur la
sécurité scolaire d'une part et les
enquêtes de victimes d'autre part
l'enquête CIVIS elle est centrée sur les
faits graves porter à la connaissance
des inspecteurs en charge des
circonscriptions du premier degré les
IEM et dans le second degré les chefs
d'établissement tout atteinte
impersonnelle est considéré comme un
fait grave c'est une mesure mensuelle
qui porte sur un échantillon
représentatif de chefs d'établissement
et d'inspecteur de l'éducation nationale
donc c'est un dispositif CIVIS qui
mesure l'évolution de la violence en
milieu scolaire en ramenant le nombre
d'atteintes graves à 1000 élèves le
nombre d'atteintes déclarés est stable
dans les écoles publiques les
établissements scolaires publient plus
privés sous contrat nous avons pour
2021-2022 nous n'avons pas les chiffres
2022 2023 nous avons trois signalements
pour mille élèves dans le premier degré
13,5 signalement pour 1000 élèves dans
les collèges
5,1 signalement pour 1000 élèves dans
les lycées d'enseignement général et
technologiques et 20,1 signalement pour
1000 élèves dans les lycées
professionnels
dans le premier degré la moitié des
faits de violence déclarées sont commis
à l'encontre d'un enseignant 54% pour
être précis et 5% en verre un personnel
autre qu'enseignant les autres faits
déclarés concernent les violences entre
élèves dans le second degré 25% des
faits de violence déclarées sont commis
à l'encontre d'un enseignant 14% à
l'encontre d'un autre personnel
dans le premier degré les principaux
auteurs sont les familles
et dans le second degré ce sont les
élèves
les violences signalées sont
majoritairement des violences verbales
61% dans le premier degré 78% dans le
second degré les violences physiques
représentant 32% des signalements dans
le premier degré 12% dans le second
degré
en complément de ces données civices
nous avons des enquêtes de victimation
qui sont menées directement auprès des
personnels elles permettent d'évaluer le
climat scolaire de mesurer les atteintes
subies par les personnels quels étaient
ou non signalées aux autorités
académiques ou et policières ces
enquêtes de victimes permettent de
compléter l'enquête CIVIS qui ne se
fonde que des faits déclarées au chef
d'établissement et aux inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale
il faut toutefois préciser que le non
signalement par le chef d'établissement
n'est pas toujours le signe
d'une crainte que la situation empire
dans 65% des cas non signalés le non
signalement provient de ce que la
situation a été traitée par l'agent de
l'éducation nationale lui-même
la DEPP a constitué un échantillon de
45000 personnels du second degré soit à
peu près 10% de la population concernée
et un échantillon de 21.000 personnes
dans le premier degré
et ces enquêtes qui existent depuis 2011
ont été étendues en 2019 à titre
d'enseignement principal elle montre que
les violences les plus graves agressions
sexuelles et armes représente 0,5% de
l'ensemble des déclarations soit environ
500 fait par an
concernant particulièrement les
atteintes à la laïcité nous observons
une augmentation des atteintes je le
disais cette augmentation s'explique en
partie par un développement de la
culture du signalement que nous
encourageons qui s'installe auprès des
établissements auprès des écoles et que
nous diffusons auprès des recteurs des
chefs d'établissement et de tous les
personnels mais c'est un fait et tous
les acteurs de terrain en conviennent
qu'il existe des entreprises locales
d'entrisme religieux dans nos écoles et
dans nos établissements depuis 2017 le
ministère a renforcé ses moyens afin de
soutenir ces personnels confrontés à des
atteintes à la laïcité avec en
particulier les équipes académiques
valeur de la République ce sont 600
personnes qui répondent à tout
signalement d'atteinte au principe de
laïcité et demande de conseils soit en
se rendant sur place soit par téléphone
également par le signalement via une
application qui a été créée en 2015 qui
est accessible au directeur d'école et
au chef d'établissement qui s'appelle
fait établissement c'est une application
sur smartphone enfin avec un formulaire
en ligne qui est accessible sur le site
officiel du ministère qui permet à des
personnels de signaler directement à
l'administration centrale toute
difficulté sans passer par la voie
hiérarchique
à partir des signalements un état des
lieux national des atteintes à la
laïcité et réaliser afin d'identifier
les phénomènes de regarder les
évolutions et d'adapter les réponses
depuis la rentrée depuis la rentrée 2022
j'ai décidé de publier mensuellement et
non plus trimestriellement les données
chiffrées relatives aux atteintes aux
principes de laïcité cet outil de suivi
et de pilotage a permis de quantifier
l'augmentation des atteintes aux
principes de laïcité et la part
croissante notamment des ports de tenue
non conformes à la loi de 2004 les
signalements d'atteinte au principe de
laïcité ont progressé depuis la création
de l'application passant de 235 en mars
2018 à 625 en mai 2023
pour faire face à la hausse des
signalements j'ai lancé un plan de
soutien au personnel directeur d'école
et chef d'établissement en novembre 2022
avec plusieurs axes la sanction
systématique et graduée du comportement
des élèves qui portent atteinte à la
laïcité lorsque ce comportement persiste
et après une phase de dialogue avec
l'élève et la famille
le renforcement de la protection et du
soutien au personnel
l'appui au chef d'établissement en cas
d'atteinte à la laïcité et le
renforcement de la formation des
personnels et en premier lieu
celle des chefs d'établissement nous
allons atteindre à la fin de
cette année scolaire près de 10000
chefs d'établissement et l'année
prochaine ce sera le tour des
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale et
des CPE
en ce qui concerne le pilotage national
et déconcentré et l'évaluation des
risques nous avons des instances à tous
les échelons et une organisation des
processus pour améliorer la sécurité des
personnels d'abord au niveau national
depuis 2012 il la prise en charge des
phénomènes de violence au sein de
l'institution scolaire c'est
structuré autour du haut fonctionnaire
de défense et de sécurité qui est
derrière moi placé sous
l'autorité du secrétaire général
toujours issu de l'encadrement supérieur
du ministère de l'Intérieur cette
organisation est ensuite déclinée en
académie les directeurs de cabinets des
recteurs les conseillers sécurité des
réacteurs les équipes mobiles de
sécurité
plus récemment depuis la rentrée 2021
les
déesses ont désigné au niveau
départemental également un référent
violence
par ailleurs ce service de défense et de
sécurité centrale du ministère est en
lien constant avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur
en 2015 après les attentats de 2015 la
coopération encore été renforcée avec
les ministères de l'Intérieur et de la
justice
par des circulaires par la mise en place
de plan particulier de mise en sûreté
des PPMS il y en avait il en avait un
depuis 2002 qui concernait les
événements naturels ou technologiques il
y en a un deuxième PPMS qui concerne les
événements d'intrusion ou d'attentat et
puis le réseau des référents justices un
par rectorat et des magistrats référents
de l'éducation nationale dans les
magistrature il y a un magistrat qui est
le magistrat référent enfin le ministère
de l'Éducation siège au clear national
la cellule de lutte contre l'islamisme
radical et le repli communautaire ça
c'est l'échelon
national et maintenant au niveau local
nous avons des
service décentrés qui sont également
partis prenantes du pilotage de la lutte
contre la violence
et de la lutte contre le séparatisme le
dazen dans chaque département siège dans
différentes commissions la clear locale
le cepraf qui s'occupe de la prévention
de la radicalisation et de
l'accompagnement des familles
l'état-major de sécurité placé sous
l'autorité du préfet du département à
l'échelle des communes c'est le chef
d'établissement qui siège dans les
conseils locaux de sécurité et de
prévention de la délinquance
en matière de procédure et je vais en
terminer là que fait-on quand un
professeur ou un personnel de
l'éducation nationale est victime de
pression de menaces ou d'agression
j'ai mentionné l'application fait
établissement créé en 2015 et
généralisée à partir de
2017-2018 cette application permet donc
au chef d'établissement directeur
d'école de signaler les faits graves
survenus dans l'espace scolaire qui
s'agit de violence entre élèves de
violence envers un personnel ou
d'atteinte aux valeurs de la République
il y a plusieurs niveaux de de
signalement sur lesquels je pourrais
revenir
si vous le
si vous le souhaitez qui peut qui
peuvent se doubler selon l'urgence et la
gravité d'une prise de contact du chef
d'établissement avec la police la
gendarmerie et la hiérarchie académique
en 2017 le ministère a créé la cellule
ministérielle de veille et d'alerte qui
reçoit les signalements pour
l'enseignement scolaire et aussi pour le
supérieur et en produit une synthèse qui
est communiquée chaque soir à mon
directeur de cabinet qui est à ma droite
et qui est en lien constant avec les
autorités académiques qu'il m'arrive
également de lire ces signalements
journaliers entre 4 et 10 personnels
selon la taille des académies assure
cette fonction de signalement et de
réaction dans cette cellule nationale
face au fait de violence
dans les dans les différentes académies
pour mémoire la loi du 24 août 2021
confortant le respect des principes de
la République créé trois nouvelles
infractions
menaces pour obtenir une dérogation en
règle de service entrave à la fonction
d'enseignant par des menaces diffusion
d'enfer d'informations à caractère privé
susceptible d'exposer un agent vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président donc la
consigne est claire
face à un fait de violence ou une
atteinte aux valeurs de la République
dans une école ou dans un établissement
le chef d'établissement le directeur
d'école l'inspecteur de circonscription
est tenu de signaler les outils de
signalement sont des outils
accessibles et parfaitement connus
de récentes enquêtes notamment de l'Ifop
ont révélé encore un phénomène
d'autocensure vous l'avez dit monsieur
le Président de la part des professeurs
et des personnels de direction un
professeur n'a pas à baissé la tête ou à
courber les Chine il est le visage de la
République l'incarnation du service
public d'éducation il est légitime par
son savoir par sa mission par
l'institution à laquelle il appartient
et qui lui doit protection j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire et de le redire à
de nombreuses reprises il ne saurait y
avoir d'omerta dans l'éducation
nationale et je serai intraitable sur
cette règle
enfin il faut à tout prix que toute
l'institution porte exactement le même
message car c'est ainsi qu'elle sera
plus forte et c'est pour cela que nous
avons créé à partir de novembre 2022 un
plan de formation valeur de la
République inédit pour les personnels de
direction les proviseurs les proviseurs
adjoint les principaux les principaux
adjoints je le disais ce sont près de
10000 personnels sur 14000 personnels de
direction qui ont été formés lors de ces
sessions de formation le message est
très clair signalé traiter et
sanctionner
les procédures disciplinaires pour tout
atteinte au personnel sont engagés
lorsque un personnel est victime de
pression de menace ou d'agressions y
compris verbales de la part d'un élève
le chef d'établissement est tenu
d'engager une procédure disciplinaire à
l'encontre de l'élève et en fonction de
la gravité des faits le chef
d'établissement dispose d'un pouvoir de
sanction jusqu'à 8 jours d'exclusion il
peut également réunir le conseil de
discipline et l'échec l'échelle de
sanctions permet alors permet alors
d'aller jusqu'à l'exclusion
définitive un mot sur la protection
fonctionnelle puisque la circulaire
ministérielle du 14 août 2020
rappelle les principes de cette garantie
l'administration doit accorder la
protection fonctionnelle dès lors que un
agent est victime dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions d'agissement qui peuvent être
qualifiés d'atteinte à l'intégrité de
des personnes de violence d’injures de
diffamation cette circulaire a été
complétée en novembre 2022 par le plan
laïcité qui rappelle la marche à suivre
en fournissant des fiches en cas de
menace sur un personnel en rappelant la
nécessité de proposer la protection
fonctionnelle la protection
fonctionnelle c'est la prise en charge
financière des frais de justice c'est la
possibilité de saisir la justice le cas
échéant d'accompagner l'agent pour
déposer plainte de lui proposer un
soutien psychologique d'autoriser une
absence en cas de besoin et lors du
dernier séminaire que nous avons tenu
sur le harcèlement la semaine dernière
le porte-parole du ministère de la
Justice a confirmé la nécessité de ces
signalements et du rapprochement entre
les services de l'éducation nationale et
les parquets pour faciliter le
traitement de ces signalements
beaucoup d'étapes ont été franchies
beaucoup a été fait depuis 2015 et je
veux rendre hommage à mes prédécesseurs
dont je poursuis l'action en adaptant
l'action du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale aux évolutions constatées j'ai
demandé au recteur de s'assurer de la
mise en œuvre effective dans chaque
école et dans chaque établissement des
instructions relatives à la lutte contre
la violence et aux atteintes au
personnel une instruction précisera cela
lors de la rentrée scolaire je ne le
répéterai jamais assez toute violence
tout atteinte aux valeurs de la
République doit être signalée et le cas
échéant sanctionner j'ai évoqué le
projet de décret actuellement soumis au
Conseil d'État qui rend obligatoire la
mise en place d'une procédure
disciplinaire en cas d'atteinte aux
valeurs de la République là encore il
s'agit de renforcer la légitimité des
équipes et de montrer la détermination
de l'institution je crois beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
Messieurs les Présidents dans la
formation des personnels et nous avons
en référence à l'enquête récente de
l'Ifop encore à faire mais cette enquête
montre aussi que les professeurs formés
se sentent plus légitimes plus outillés
pour aborder les parties des programmes
qui peuvent faire l'objet de
contestation c'est pourquoi sans vouloir
aucunement
relativiser des phénomènes réellement
inquiétants préoccupant l'augmentation
des signalements d'atteinte au principe
de laïcité et probablement aussi la
preuve que les chefs d'établissement
l'ont compris ont compris pardon que le
signalement n'est pas un aveu de
faiblesse voilà donc les étapes
vers lesquelles nous allons du point de
vue de la mise en œuvre du point de vue
de la formation du point de vue de la
protection des personnels beaucoup a été
fait nous avons encore à faire
certainement mais je suis maintenant
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
Messieurs les Présidents à votre
disposition
le ministre sans plus tarder nous allons
donner la parole à nos collègues ce
qu'ils l'ont demandé en tout cas en
commençant par Jacques coopéra
ensuite François bonhomme c'est ça
Sylvie Robert et Henri Leroy il y aura
une deuxième vague de questions par la
suite
le ministre Messieurs les Présidents mes
chers collègues sénateurs
au moment de ce drame
vous nous avez dit que il était de votre
devoir de protéger la protection de vos
personnels
vous nous avez cité des chiffres du
ministère qui montraient ces difficultés
là moi je voudrais reprendre un sondage
de l'Ifop qui dit que l'enseignement
fait face à l'expression du fait
religieux à l'école et aux atteintes à
la laïcité de 2018 à 2022 le nombre de
profs qui s'étaient autour censuré afin
d'éviter tout incident sur les questions
religieuses et passer de 36 à 56%
. on a le sentiment en tout cas moi j'ai
le sentiment qu'il y a un problème de
ligne au sein du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale depuis de très
longues années j'ai sentiments que il
s'agit en règle générale de ne pas faire
de vagues de ne pas blesser et en 2015
j'avais fait un rapport sur faire
revenir la République à l'école en
s'appuyant sur les propos de Jean-Pierre
Robin et on se rend compte que depuis
2015 rien n'a changé jusqu'au drame du
16 octobre 2020 vous nous parlez d'un
pilotage national des déconcentré moi
j'ai le sentiment que nous avons
une institution qui est sous l'emprise
encore et encore et encore de Jules
Ferry et de si préceptes est plus grave
encore le problème endémique peut être
au sein de l'éducation nationale par
rapport à la ligne qu'il doit instituer
la question que je vous pose pour être
posée aux différents ministres
d'éducation nationale mais je vous la
pose à vous parce que vous êtes en
situation ce jour est-ce que vous feriez
encore votre ou est-ce que les ministres
feraient encore le ciel ou la
reconnaissance que Jules Ferry adressait
aux instituteurs dans sa circulaire du
17 novembre
1883 il disait et je crois qu'on
retrouve le fond du problème qui reste
latent au sein ce ministère et qui à un
moment donné ne protège pas suffisamment
nos enseignants vis-à-vis d'une certaine
ligne il disait au moment de proposer
aux élèves aprèscepte une maxime
quelconque demandez-vous s'il se trouve
à votre connaissance un seul honnête
homme qui puisse être froissé de ce que
vous
demandez-vous si un père de famille je
dis un seul présent à votre classe et
vous écoutant pourrait de bonnes foi
refuser son assentiment à ce qu'il vous
entendrait dire si oui abstenez-vous on
se rend compte que beaucoup
s'absciennent parce qu'ils sont encore
dans cette histoire de Jules Ferry sinon
parler à dimanche car ce que vous allez
communiquer à l'enfant ce n'est pas
votre propre sagesse c'est la sagesse du
genre humain en faisant bien sûr la part
des changements qui se sont produits dès
lors
j'ai le vrai véritablement ce sentiment
là que l'éducation nationale Le
ministère que ça soit la gouvernance et
que ce soit les services de concentré
sont restés dans cette philosophie de
Jules Ferry et tant qu'il resteront dans
cette philosophie de Jules Ferry on
arrivera pas dépasser et on arrivera pas
à éviter ces drames merci
monsieur le Président oui monsieur
ministre moi je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt vous avez développé
des propos sur les moyens de développer
la culture du signalement
des propos impeccables vous avez parlé
des référents des nouvelles applications
de veille tout ça apparaît fabuleux pour
au moins pour mesurer un phénomène
nouveau qui concerne l'enregistrement
des attentes à la laïcité donc là dessus
je n'ai rien à redire le problème c'est
que vous êtes ministre
et que moi j'attends de vous monsieur le
ministre que vous preniez des décisions
claires nous avons la multiplication des
attentes
de départements avec mon collecteur
Antonelli nous avons eu à la rentrée
des élèves de plus en plus nombreux qui
sont venus vêtus d'une à Baya alors nous
avons laissé le temps de la médiation de
toutes les autorités académiques pour
essayer de trouver une solution liée à
la médiation et
au bout de quelques temps voyant que ça
ne s'arrangeait pas certains égards ça
s'aggraver la même même la ministre la
professeure qui a fait une remontrance
une simple remontrance à cet élève vêtue
de la Bayard une des élèves c'est vu
menacer de mort et mis sous protection
policière je vous interroge en novembre
sur ce que vous entendiez de donner
comme directive clair sur l'appréciation
du caractère religieux de la Baya en
l'espèce et vous avez dit que cette
appréciation relevée du chef
d'établissement c'est-à-dire que le
problème déplacer et la pression s'est
déplacée sur le chef d'établissement moi
il en quoi nous avons toujours ce
problème et ce problème est à remettre
en situation avec une situation où
manifestement les signes et manifestants
religieuses sont de plus en plus
prégnantes depuis l'affaire de faire du
collège de Creil 1989 quand même et déjà
nous avions quand même des inquiétudes
entre-temps nous avons la loi de 2004
sur sur l'interdiction des ports
religieux à l'école par ailleurs à
l'école pour la protéger contre ce type
d'influence de la société qui empêche
vraiment de concrétiser le problème de
la laïcité auquel je vous êtes vous
juste titre vous dites vouloir défendre
l'école publique et ses principes
malheureusement vous ne prenez pas les
décisions je ne vois que de la terre
moment du refus de tranché qui crée une
situation de confusion qui ne fait que
s'aggraver et qui de toute façon ces
situations vont revenir monsieur le
ministre alors vous ne vous abritez
d'ailleurs la question juridique pour
savoir si décréter que la Baya est un
signe religieux serait susceptible de
recours ça c'est sûr et peut-être
d'annulation en attendant les chaises
établissements ne peuvent plus
fonctionner comme cela et supporter la
pression extérieure pour vraiment
s'assurer que au sein de l'école on est
dans la neutralité et en dehors de toute
influence religieuse nous avons fait une
proposition de loi qui s'appelle rentre
obligatoire la tenue commune monsieur le
ministre là tu nous communes ça a quand
même quelques vertus c'est un facteur de
cohésion qui manque si cruellement
aujourd'hui à l'école c'est un facteur
qui évacue nécessairement la question du
port de signe religieux à l'école par
définition puisque là il n'est plus
question de distinction et de y compris
social d'ailleurs pas que religieuse et
puis c'est surtout un facteur de
relégétation de l'autorité du professeur
dire qu'à l'école on n'est pas hors de
l'école c'est un lieu tout à fait
particulier qu'on doit protéger et j'ose
dire excuser du gros mots sanctuarisé
donc monsieur le ministre moi j'aimerais
que vous preniez des décisions claires
c'est ce qu'on attend d'un ministre qui
viennent vraiment rompre cette ambiguïté
cette éco cette côté équivoque et qui ne
fait que nuire encore une fois
à l'application et à rendre concret le
principe de laïcité
merci Monsieur Bonhomme je rappelle
simplement les deux minutes par
intervenants
je sais que c'est difficile mais j'ai ce
rôle en gras de faire la police donc je
vous lis voilà je crois que c'est Madame
Sylvie Robert c'est ça et puis ensuite
Monsieur Henri Leroy
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup pour
l'explication et les présentations des
diverses mesures qui ont été prises
depuis ce drame c'est vrai qu'il y avait
aussi les préconisations du rapport de
et un certain nombre était d'ailleurs
assez intéressantes à soulever il y
avait aussi bien sûr il y a eu la
circulaire de novembre 2020 et la loi du
24 août 2021 alors c'est vrai qu'on a un
peu de recul quand même aujourd'hui et
vous avez donc présenté toutes ces
mesures et j'aimerais vous poser trois
questions assez rapide pour respecter
mon temps
vous avez parlé beaucoup de la
protection fonctionnelle aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous disposez d'éléments
statistiques sur le recours à la
protection fonctionnelle pour les
enseignants
le nombre de demandes la proportion des
mécanismes qui ont été mis en oeuvre le
pourcentage de refus et surtout le délai
moyen de réponse pour convenir que un
moment quand on met en place des mesures
non seulement elles sont efficaces mais
on peut les justement on mesurer les
justement l'efficacité deuxième question
l'article 431-1 du code pénal prévoit
depuis la loi du 24 août 2021 confortant
le respect des principes de la
République de sanctionner et vous l'avez
aussi mentionné le fait d'entraver
l'exercice de la fonction d'enseignant
là aussi à votre connaissance cet
article a-t-il à ce jour déjà donné lieu
à des condamnations
et enfin troisième question un peu à
côté mais qui pour moi est très
importante parce que on a beaucoup
légiféré c'est en ce moment on travaille
sur le
la sécurisation du numérique on a parlé
de cyber-harcèlement est-ce que
l'ensemble des services académiques sont
désormais pourvus de cellules de veille
des réseaux sociaux je vous remercie
beaucoup
monsieur le roi
merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de rentrer dans vos directives
et d'exclure tout ce qui est tout le
verbe bien superfétatoire je suis le
ministre selon l'autonome de Solidarité
Laïque 55 % ont des professeurs disent
que la laïcité est atteinte à
l'intérieur de l'école et 51% veulent
quitter leur métier en l'occurrence
50000 professeurs ont été fondés
que prévoit le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale pour protéger un professeur et
son établissement face à des menaces
proférées par des parents d'élèves
motivés par des considérations
religieuses
près de trois ans après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty les professeurs
disposent-ils d'un clip pédagogique sur
les éléments de langage à tenir des
attitudes de solidarité à avoir d'une
manière de s'opposer à une menace
extérieure des procédures spécifiques
qui permettent d'accéder rapidement à un
service interne ou externe de protection
devant la multiplication de situations
de harcèlement de menaces d'agressions
subis à l'école de la République
avons-nous renforcé en période de crise
l'accompagnement des chefs
d'établissement et du corps enseignant
du collège du bois donne à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine un signalement
pour fait d'établissements et remonter à
l'académie de Versailles et au ministère
aujourd'hui
c'est près de 50
faits de d'établissement qui sont qui
arrivent au ministère semble-t-il
comment et par qui sont-ils traités et
enfin Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous informer sur les actions et les
résultats du conseil des sages de la
laïcité dont vous avez considérablement
étendu l'émission merci pour vos
réponses
va vous laisser répondre à cette
première série de questions
je vous remercie
madame messieurs les sénateurs Messieurs
les Présidents je vais peut-être
commencer par cette belle citation
monsieur le sénateur Jacques repérain
que vous avez
que vous nous avez donné de Jules Ferry
parler hardiment de la sagesse du genre
humain
voyez-vous je ne vois pas en quoi cette
citation serait aujourd'hui dépassée
elle me semble encore très belle et de
voir être défendu parler hardiments
c'est une manière de dire lorsque l'on
s'adresse aux professeur
n'ayez crainte adressez-vous directement
aux élèves ne reculez pas devant les
menaces ne reculez pas devant les
contestations pédagogiques et c'est
l'occasion pour moi de dire que les
contestations pédagogiques
un fait qui tend à être parfois un peu
qui passe un peu dans l'ombre si je puis
dire par rapport au signalement de tenue
religieuse mais nous y prêtons très
grande attention au contestations
pédagogique ou refus de cours et elle se
loge dans des disciplines et sur des
questions parfois extrêmement
inattendues par exemple la contestation
de la préhistoire voilà quelque chose
qui est bien présent
voilà et qui pourrait surprendre
au premier abord donc je pense que je
peux reprendre à mon compte ce que dit
Jules Ferry en revanche là où je vous
suis sans doute c'est que nous avons
désormais des services déconcentrés de
l'éducation nationale et puis que nous
sommes aux antipodes d'une politique de
pas de vague si on était sur une
politique de pas de vague et bien bien
nous ne publions pas chaque mois les
chiffres relatifs aux atteintes à la
laïcité par exemple
nous ne publierions pas également les
chiffres relatifs à un certain nombre de
violences subies par les agents de
l'éducation nationale donc nous sommes
au plus loin d'une politique de pas de
vague il est évident qu'il faut signaler
et qu'il faut
que c'est fait soient connus parce que
la connaissance c'est la première étape
pour les combattre et pour faire reculer
les forces hostiles à la connaissance
des forces obscurantistes
l'ignorance
et puis celles et ceux qui veulent du
mal à l'école de la République
monsieur le député pardon sénateur
bonhomme excusez moi vous avez fait
allusion au lycée Bourdel de Montauban
et en effet au moment des vacances de la
Toussaint il y avait de mémoires une
vingtaine de cas de jeunes filles
portant des abayas à la rentrée des
classes début novembre au lycée Bourdel
il en restait deux qui avaient refusé de
d'enlever leurs abayas puis une et une
procédure au conseil de discipline était
engagés contre elles en novembre la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé cette
situation donc l'Académie concernée qui
est l'académie de Toulouse s'est penché
avec et beaucoup de vigueur sur le cas
du lycée Bourdel ce qui est l'occasion
pour moi de dire que nous avons besoin
d'une cartographie nationale que nous
allons établir à ce sujet que nous avons
un certain nombre d'établissements qui
ne sont pas si nombreux mais qui
concentre un nombre élevé de signalement
à l'échelle des rectorats des académies
et à l'échelle nationale je voudrais
aussi faire allusion à la circulaire de
novembre 2022 qui était une circulaire
visant à répondre à la hausse des
signalements pour tenu religieuse et je
vous ferai enfin
je remarquerai enfin monsieur le
sénateur que
les par rapport à la loi même à l'époque
du début des années 2000 donc à la loi
de 2004 et a fortiori à la situation
hantée
la les tenues ou les signes religieux
ont évolué puisque à l'époque il
s'agissait du voile or les situations de
port de voile sont devenues anecdotiques
il s'agit plutôt là de port de tenue qui
sont des ports de tenue par intention
religieuse et c'est évidemment là que
l'on se heurte parfois à des difficultés
d'interprétation mais la règle quoi
qu'il en soit avec l'appui des équipes
valeurs de la République c'est bien
l'application stricte de la loi de 2004
et ça je ne bougerai pas de cette
application stricte de la loi de 2004
quant à votre appréciation sur le port
de tenue
scolaire si j'ai bien compris votre
votre point si vous avez la curiosité de
regarder ce qui se passe dans un certain
nombre de pays étrangers vous verrez
comment les élèves peuvent
agrémenter leur tenue de toutes sortes
de petits symboles signe foulard etc qui
montre que le port de tenue ne règle pas
les situations comme on pourrait le
penser et libre aux établissements il
suffit de cela pour cela d'une
modification du règlement intérieur de
proposer le port d'une tenue c'est c'est
possible
je vous ai indiqué que je n'étais pas je
l'ai indiqué à plusieurs reprises que je
n'étais pas favorable à cela ne
serait-ce que parce que elle ne
résoudrait pas le problème que vous sous
leviez je voudrais me tourner maintenant
vers madame la sénatrice Robert à propos
de la protection fonctionnelle donc nous
avons eu pour l'année
2000 alors je regarde les chiffres
précis pour l'année 2022 nous avons eu
[Musique]
2739 demandes de protection
personnelle
de protection fonctionnelle pardon pour
les portes personnelles enseignants des
premiers et second degré et 994 demandes
pour les autres pour les autres
personnels
les
77% de ces
demandes ont donné lieu trois protection
fonctionnelle ont été ont été approuvés
voilà les chiffres dont nous disposons
et je crois que un calcul montre qu'en
fait on est très légèrement au dessus de
80%. donc on est aux alentours de 80 %
d'approbation des demandes lors les
situations de refus sont liées à
plusieurs faits notamment le fait que la
protection fonctionnelle doit être
accordée à un agent qui est dans
l'exercice de ces fonctions et non pas
un agent qui se trouve
qui se trouve en dehors en dehors de ces
fonctions
pour une raison ou
une autre j'ajoute également madame la
sénatrice que
il a cette c'est le c'est très net
depuis l'assassinat de Samuel Paty que
la protection fonctionnelle peut être
accordée par l'administration de
l'éducation nationale de façon directe
sans même que l'agent est à formuler la
demande et donc il nous avons un certain
nombre de cas comme cela lorsque nous
estimons que ce soit au niveau du dazen
du rectorat ou du chef d'établissement
que la situation l'exige c'est
l'éducation nationale qui prend
l'initiative d'accorder la protection
fonctionnelle de façon de façon
absolument directe à propos de cas
d'entrave à la fonction d'enseignants
nous avons eu une première condamnation
qui a été prononcée le 13 septembre 2022
par le tribunal correctionnel du
Puy-en-Velay
à propos d'un
parent d'élèves qui a été condamné à 12
mois d'emprisonnement avec sursis
pour
des faits commis à l'encontre de
l'institution mais aussi des faits
commis à l'encontre d'un principal de
collèges donc là il s'agit d'entraver la
fonction de personnel de direction c'est
le c'est le cas que je qui est sous mes
yeux au moment où je vous parle il est
possible qu'il y ait à l'heure actuelle
d'autres affaires qui soient instruites
par les tribunaux correctionnels à
propos des cellules de veille des
réseaux sociaux nous avons donc une une
cellule
à l'échelle de veille à l'échelle
du ministère et dans chaque académie
c'est au service de communication que
cette tâche est dévolue il y a une
veille des réseaux sociaux en lien avec
la cellule nationale qui fait son
travail de veille sur les questions de
violence mais aussi sur les questions de
cyber-harcèlement en ayant à l'esprit
tout de même il faut le dire avec
modestie que les réseaux sociaux ne sont
pas simples à
scanner en permanence
j'ai moi-même reçu les responsables de
des grands réseaux sociaux il y a
quelques semaines pour voir comment on
pouvait avancer sur ces questions la loi
européenne du
la loi du service digitaux qui va entrer
en fonction
partiellement le 23 août prochain
devrait nous aider mais il est clair que
nous avons besoin de l'aide des réseaux
sociaux pour
pour scanner et pour
identifier les menaces qui peuvent peser
sur des agents d'éducation nationale ou
bien sur des élèves dans le cas du
cyber-harcèlement
le
monsieur le sénateur Leroy vous
m'interrogez à propos de la protection
des des professeurs elle passe par la
formation de nos personnels nous sommes
entre 250 000 et 300 000 aujourd'hui
personnels formés elle passe aussi par
les équipes valeurs de la République
auquel j'ai fait allusion et je voudrais
à ce sujet si rendre hommage à ces
fonctionnaires qui se déplacent
très fréquemment sur le terrain pour
assister lorsque des situations se
posent en particulier du point de vue de
d'atteinte à la laïcité et puis je
signale également le fait que
l'application fait établissement elle
permet aussi de d'avoir une je dirais
une une photographie de ce qui se passe
avec plusieurs niveaux d'alerte y
compris un niveau maximal qui met en
alerte notre cellule nationale à
laquelle je faisais allusion
précédemment placé près du haut
fonctionnaire de défense et de sécurité
c'est le niveau 4 le niveau 3 c'est
l'alerte au niveau du rectorat le niveau
2 c'est l'alerte au niveau de la
direction académique et le niveau 1
c'est pour des faits moins importants
qui reste dans le cadre de
l'établissement je ne dis pas que tout
est parfait monsieur le sénateur vous
indiquez que je brossais un tableau
merveilleux pour reprendre votre
expression ou parfait loin de moi cette
idée et je ne suis pas là devant vous
pour expliquer que la situation est en
tout point merveilleuse mais je vous dis
ce que nous faisons je vous dis que nous
allons aussi loin que possible je vous
dis aussi que la coopération avec les
ministères de l'Intérieur et de la
justice et je me félicite au passage de
la fluidité des liens que nous avons à
l'échelle nationale mais aussi à
l'échelle départementale avec les
services des ministères de l'Intérieur
et de la justice que cela oui fonctionne
et que cela fonctionne de façon à notre
sens satisfaisante nous avons encore à
avancer et nous avons beaucoup avancé
alors on va prendre toutes vos questions
en commençant par Alexandra borchio
Fontain
Monique de Marco Céline Brulin
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre madame la
représentante de la commission des lois
monsieur le Président de la Commission
Culture mes chers collègues face à la
recrudescence dont des actes de violence
envers les enseignants il est évidemment
crucial que des mesures soient mises en
oeuvre pour garantir leur sécurité les
enseignants se dévouent chaque jour pour
transmettre le savoir à nos enfants ils
mérite évidemment la protection de
l'État il est inconcevable que dans
notre République certains d'entre eux
vivent encore dans la peur constante
subissent des intimidations et des
violences verbales et parfois physiques
le climat social a évolué ces dernières
années nous le savons tous il est plus
imprévisible plus instable plus violent
il est donc impératif que les politiques
publiques menées s'adaptent à ces
changements monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais connaître les actions
entreprises par votre ministère
permettant de détecter les signes
faibles afin d'agir rapidement en cas de
situation à risque alors j'entends par
signion faible et bien les premiers
signes de contestation d'un élève par
exemple ou d'un parent il ne faut pas
attendre évidemment un geste physique
pour caractériser une agression
j'aimerais savoir comment vous avez
transmis finalement concrètement c'est
directives aux enseignants afin qu'ils
puissent facilement détecter les
premiers signaux je pense par exemple
peut-être un référentiel chaque
enseignant d'analyse peut être pas de la
même façon les premiers signaux je pense
notamment aux nouveaux enseignants en
tout cas il est urgent que le
gouvernement mette en place une
politique de tolérance zéro les auteurs
de pression menaces et agressions
doivent être poursuivies et condamnés
avec la plus grande fermeté je vous
remercie en tout cas pour votre
attention et j'attends avec impatience
votre réponse éclairante
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le fait que vous croyez à
la formation du personnel et qu'il y a
beaucoup à faire vous avez effectivement
évoqué le fait qu'il y a 10 000 chefs
d'établissement formés et à la réponse
de mon collègue vous avez parlé de 250
000 personnels formés j'aurais voulu
savoir quel type de formation est-ce
qu'elle est suffisante est-ce que c'est
une formation volontaire
est-ce que c'est sur le temps de libre
ou le temps donc d'exercice c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
pour avoir été enseignante
je suis assez inquiète de l'enquête du
service sur les atteintes graves et
surtout en ce qui se passe en collège
donc les chiffres sont assez
impressionnants et quand vous avez parlé
de sanctions par rapport aux élèves vous
avez parlé d'une sanction avec une
procédure disciplinaire graduée etc
allonge quelle exclusion
le problème c'est qu'un élève qui est en
collège donc
quand il est exclu va être partir dans
un autre établissement est-ce qu'il ne
serait pas possible parce que à mon avis
de réfléchir à cette sanction
d'exclusion qui fait que reporter le
problème dans un autre établissement où
l'élève n'a peut-être pas compris du
tout le fait qu'il a été sanctionné sur
l'exclusion comment comment pourrait
procéder de façon à éviter l'exclusion
et que ce soit quand même une sanction
qu'il puisse être profitable à cet
enfant
Céline Brulin merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
je voudrais faire écho à la une des
premières questions qui a posé le
président buffet sur les liens avec les
renseignements territoriaux et je crois
à moins que je n'ai pas été suffisamment
attentif que vous n'avez pas apporté de
réponse précise sur ce plan là quels
sont les liens et qu'elle pour aller un
peu plus loin même qu'elle comment
l'éducation nationale peut-elle faire
prendre la mesure s'il y a besoin bien
évidemment au renseignement territoriaux
qu'il considère d'éventuelles menaces
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner des
exemples là aussi assez concrets
d'intervention de référent laïcité qui
pourrait être sollicité par des
enseignants quelle est la nature et le
type d'aide d'apport de conseils qu'ils
peuvent apporter aux enseignants
sur la veille sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez évoqué une cellule au plan
national et ensuite en gros les services
comme si j'ai bien compris directorat
combien cela mobilise-t-il de personnel
et est-ce suffisant à vos yeux
quand je pose la question c'est que je
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas tout à
fait le cas et comme on sait que ça
n'est pas le cas dans d'autres domaines
ça pose évidemment question et puis une
dernière question dont vous comprendrez
le caractère un peu provocateur mais qui
a quand même du sens à mes yeux est-ce
que vous ne considérez pas que dans la
nécessité de conforter l'autorité de
l'institution éducation nationale
lorsque le président de la République
est amené à faire des annonces qui
relèvent je dirais si je disais du
détail je serai un peu désobligeante
mais qui ne relève pas forcément de la
fonction de président de la République
est-ce que ça ne conduit pas à affaiblir
aussi l'institution éducation nationale
merci
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais s'il vous plaît un
éclaircissement très net à un cas
pratique il s'agit d'un élève qui a un
comportement inadéquat avec un
professeur comportement répréhensible ce
comportement et sanctionné la sanction
est appliquée la semaine suivante
rebelote si je puis dire comportement
inadéquat le professeur demande une
sanction et le chef d'établissement dit
ah non ce n'est pas possible cet élève a
déjà été sanctionné en gros c'est
l'application du droit commun de la
règle de droit commun qui dit non pie
cinidem sauf que on n'est pas dans un
tribunal on est dans une dans un collège
dans une école est-ce vrai qu'il existe
une directive en ce sens où on ne peut
pas sanctionner un enfant deux fois pour
la même chose si ce n'est pas vrai merci
de de rétablir la vérité auprès des
chefs d'établissement qui peut être
eux-mêmes transpose quelque chose qui
qui n'est pas réel puisque on aboutit
alors à des comportements qui deviennent
de moins en moins punissable et
acceptable
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez dû dire au début de
votre propos que l'école n'est pas
épargnée par les courants qui traversent
la société or il me semble bien que
l'école n'est pas en marge de la société
mais elle fondements de la société et
c'est un petit peu nous en sommes tous
d'accord de là que tout part or il me
semble que vous avez des positions
tranchées catégoriques sur certains
sujets et sur d'autres vous semblez
hésiter et non pas qu'un ministre
doivent être omnipotent mais un ministre
dans la situation le recommande doit
avoir la main qui ne tremble pas sur
certains sujets pour reprendre la
question de la Baya vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises que c'était un
vêtement religieux par destination d'où
la difficulté de trancher sur le port de
la Baya or nous avons su trancher les
différer en 2004 et bien avant sur le
port du voile mais par contre lorsque
vous hésitez sur ce sujet vous n'hésitez
pas sur la solution qui a été proposée
moi c'est une idée que j'ai beaucoup
défendu au Sénat avec le soutien de mes
collègues sur cette solution qui est
proposée qui n'est peut-être pas la
panacée mais qui favorise le sentiment
d'appartenance et qui a le mérite d'être
un outil pour la communauté éducative
sur laquelle repose beaucoup de choses
et qui est effectivement mon colloque
mon collègue François bonhomme en a
parlé le vêtement la tenue d'un vêtement
d'un vêtement commun aux établissements
scolaires mais façon 2023 avec une
souplesse bien évidemment dans le choix
de la tenue qui elle peut être
réglementaire mais on a vite déterminé
que si cette idée ne passait pas par la
loi elle ne serait pas efficace puisque
des expérimentations ont montré qu'elle
n'était pas suivies des faits on n'a pas
dit que c'était la solution universelle
mais on a dit qu'on voulait un débat sur
cette question et des députés de votre
majorité on dit d'ailleurs qu'ils
étaient d'accord et qu'il vous demandait
un débat or sur ce sujet vous êtes
catégorique en disant que cette question
pourrait être détournée et que ça avait
été prouvé or évidemment si à chaque
fois qu'on devait voter une loi ou
décider d'un règlement on ne le faisait
pas au motif qu'il pouvait être
détournés on ne légiférerait jamais dans
ce que je vous demande monsieur ministre
c'est de revenir sur votre position et
de dire si oui ou non vous seriez prêt à
ouvrir un dialogue sur ce sujet qui me
semble important et qui peut être un
outil efficace dans les situations
difficiles que nous connaissons je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup
Toine Bora
ton micro s'il te plaît
et là c'est mieux je vais je vais me
rapprocher de mon collègue
Claude
donc je reprends monsieur le ministre je
disais qu'il était un constat général
que les enseignants éprouvent de plus en
plus de difficultés à faire respecter
leur décision notamment du fait d'une
intrusion excessive des parents qui
remettent rarement en cause la parole de
leur enfant mais qui remettent en cause
la parole de l'enseignant contestant les
remarques les sanctions voir les
contenus des cours les sorties scolaires
ou encore les notes phénomènes qui s'est
encore amplifiée depuis la réforme du
bac et le contrôle continu les
enseignants subissent désormais des
pressions des parents voire de leur
hiérarchie pour remonter les notes
Horse cela n'a pas toujours été le cas
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas de
remettre en cause l'autorité de
l'enseignant alors je voudrais savoir
pourquoi selon vous l'autorité de
l'enseignant est-elle remise en cause
aujourd'hui par les élèves et par les
parents et puis comme la Punité entraîne
la récidive je voudrais savoir ce que
vous proposez pour restaurer le respect
envers les enseignants et stopper net
ainsi cette dérive je vous remercie
monsieur le Président le président seul
ministre de manière vraiment très
succincte quand je vous entends et quand
on fait le on recense en fait le toutes
les structures à l'évidence sur le
papier en tout cas les nombreux
dispositifs existent
constituent en quelque sorte une
superposition de de structure de
cellules d'écoute et de recueil de la
parole des enseignants et des et des
retours de terrain des enseignants mais
c'est l'ancien enseignant qui parle
aussi au commencement des des remontées
d'information et des sanctions
éventuelles à l'encontre des
élèves il y a les conseils de discipline
que les chefs d'établissement c'est une
la palissade et c'est parfois souvent
d'étouffer dans l'œuf
un pour ne pas nuire à la répétition de
leur établissement 2 éventuellement à
leur propre réputation
et donc ça rejoint ce qu'a dit François
bonhomme tout à l'heure peut-être
manque-t-il un signal j'allais dire une
volonté politique pour qu'on hésite plus
à
tenir des conseils de discipline lorsque
des dérives sont observées et pour qu'on
en finisse avec l'omerta ou la
résignation selon que l'on se place d'un
côté ou de l'autre donc ma question
c'est ce ministre quelle directive clair
donnez-vous aux enseignants et aux chefs
d'établissement pour enclencher les
procédures dès l'apparition des premiers
troubles par évidemment la voix des
directeurs bien évidemment et pour ne
plus hésiter à se confronter le plus tôt
possible aux agressions dans son victime
les enseignants je vous remercie
merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
moi j'ai plusieurs questions d'abord les
chiffres que vous avez évoqués quand on
passe de 3 fourmis dans la réalité ça
fait de plus de 21000 signalements donc
ça reste quand même assez substantiel
et donc je pense qu'un moment il faut
dire le les vrais chiffres et les vrais
noms pour comprendre pas pour faire peur
mais pour que la réalité
soit un peu plus évidente que le 3 pour
mine
est-ce que sur ces
signalement il y a une étude qui est
réalisée
concernant l'âge de ceux qui qui ont
harcelé ou qui ont provoqué l'incident
ou l'accident ou voir le délit est-ce
que on a des déterminismes enfin en tout
cas une sectorisation géographique
est-ce que on est plutôt dans des
quartiers plutôt en difficulté sociale
que dans des quartiers plus privilégiés
ou est-ce une journée face à un
phénomène complètement systémique qui
serait de même nature quel que soit
l'établissement scolaire en d'autres
termes quand on fait un très bon
diagnostic précis on peut agir plus
précisément et on met le bon traitement
et dans les reproches qui ont été faits
parce qu'on a fait pas mal d'auditions
sur ce sujet là à la commission culture
à la grande époque du hashtag padvac qui
existe encore sur Twitter je me suis le
ministre et il y a encore beaucoup de
choses qui se font sur ce fameux hashtag
c'est dire à quel point quand même les
choses sont encore vivantes et vécues
avec violence
parmi les propositions il y avait de la
part d'un certain nombre d'enseignants
moi j'ai en mémoire une audition assez
assez difficile à vivre de témoignages
qui s'étaient déroulés à huis clos à la
commission il y avait la demande que on
met pas les plus les moins expérimentés
dans les établissements qui sont dans la
situation la plus difficile face à ces
situations de violence
la loi ce risque d'entrisme religieux et
face à ces atteintes répétées voire
difficiles à laïcité avec même des
difficultés enseignants à enseigner dans
les cours d'histoire par exemple des
éléments aussi essentiels de notre
histoire commune comme la Shoah par
exemple pour ne citer que cet aspect là
mais c'est celui qui est revenu assez
régulièrement et donc est-ce que ça
c'est une mesure qui a été envisagée qui
est mise en oeuvre c'est-à-dire de
choisir finalement des enseignants un
peu plus capés plus résistants qui ont
plus l'habitude de la pédagogie plutôt
que de mettre des des enseignants plus
novice en d'autres termes est-ce qu'on a
des postes à profil et puis ma deuxième
question porte sur les écoles hors
contrat parce que est-ce qu'il y a des
remontées d'incidents d'accidents voire
de délits qui remonte des écoles hors
contrats et est-ce que parce qu'il y a
fort à parier que ça existe également et
à ce que vous avez dans vos attributions
et dans les écrans radars du ministère
une surveillance particulière de ces
établissements sur ces sujets là puisque
ce sont des élèves qui sont un peu hors
des yeux de la République une partie du
temps je vous remercie
pour conclure je vais rajouter trois
questions monsieur le ministre assez
diverses d'abord suite à un communiqué
du comité des sages de laïcité du 14
janvier 2022 qui est relatait un
problème en fait d'entrée au sein de des
enseignants dans un établissement de
l'académie de Créteil et un incident
sérieux lors d'une formation sur les
valeurs de la République avec les
représentants du personnel enseignant
qui ont dénoncé a priori un contenu qui
aurait tout avoir avec l'islamophobie
l'affaire est allé assez loin puisque
les formateurs ont déposé plainte et
elle a eu des répercussions sur Internet
c'est évidemment
des faits qui sont tout à fait
regrettables je voudrais savoir si c'est
fait sont totalement marginaux ou est-ce
que vous avez connaissance de faits
similaires et quels sont les actions les
poursuites de du ministère quand de tels
sont constatées sur un sujet qui n'a pas
été abordé la question des programmes en
tout cas dans le dialogue que vous
pouvez avoir entre le Conseil national
des programmes et vous-même lors de
l'élaboration de programme je parle pas
de l'application par les enseignants
est-ce que depuis que vous êtes en
fonction vous avez dans les justement ce
dialogue avec le Conseil national des
programmes eu des réflexions sur ça on
peut pas l'enseigner parce que ça mettra
les enseignants en difficulté ou au
contraire
senti que le Conseil national des
programmes freinait par
directement et
ne mettez pas en dans le programme des
éléments qui pour autant devraient être
et troisième question toujours le
Conseil des sages de laïcité avait fait
une demande
que dans la semaine du 16 octobre une
journée entière du temps scolaire soit
16 octobre c'est l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty une journée entière du temps
scolaire soit consacrée à la
commémoration de cet attentat ainsi qu'à
la transmission des valeurs de la
République je voudrais savoir quel est
votre point de vue par rapport à cette
demande du conseil des sages
merci mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nomment la présidente monsieur
le Président je vais reprendre donc les
questions qui m'ont été posées à
commencer par les vôtres madame la
sénatrice borchio Fontain à propos des
signaux faibles sur lesquels vous
m'interrogez et en effet nous avons une
grille de de type de
disons signaux ou de forme de violence
qui comprennent des ce qu'on peut
appeler des signaux faibles par exemple
la rubrique moquerie ou insultes
ou bien
la
rubrique qui pourrait alors d'un niveau
supérieur de refus ou contestation
d'enseignement
nous sommes très attentifs au fait que
ne serait-ce que à niveau 1 les chefs
d'établissement signalent des
altercations par exemple ou des parents
qui pourraient être
inhabituellement agressif
en venant contester une note ou un
jugement de fin de trimestre et donc
nous signalons nous
nous répertorions c'est ces signes pas
nécessairement pour leur donner des
conséquences immédiates mais nous
répertorions ces signes
et en effet je pense qu'il est important
d'être attentif à ces signaux faibles
l'expression me semble juste
sans pour autant entrer dans une phase
qui serait une phase de
suractivité par rapport à l'école ou les
établissements scolaires où il y a comme
dans toute communauté humaine il peut y
avoir des tensions il peut y avoir
parfois des éclats de voix entre les uns
et les autres mais il y a un niveau
d'attention qui est qui est élevé
à l'égard de ce qui pourrait relever
d'un début de menace qui pourrait
évoluer de manière négative par la suite
madame la sénatrice de Marco en effet la
formation est obligatoire la formation à
la fois des personnels enseignants mais
aussi des personnels de direction
si je ne m'abuse il s'agit d'une
formation d'une journée en deux fois une
journée
c'est une journée pour les chefs
d'établissement et ces deux jours sous
réserve nous allons vérifier cela donc
je ne veux pas m'aventurer sur ce point
précis si vous me le permettez vous avez
dit que les atteintes en collège étaient
préoccupantes et en effet dans les
données que nous avons les collèges sont
de loin les niveaux ou les atteintes ou
les phénomènes de violence sont les plus
élevés de même que les atteintes à la
laïcité ça baisse ensuite en lycée
c'était moins élevé en primaire il n'y a
aucun doute à propos des élèves il y a
en effet des procédures d'exclusion
définitive pour
2021-2022 il y a eu
19178 exclusions définitive en collège
en lycée général et technologique
3724 exclusion définitive et en lycée
professionnel
4688 exclusions définitive pour un total
de 27 590 exclusions définitive pour
l'année scolaire 2021 2022 c'est une
façon peut-être monsieur le sénateur
pied-noir de de signaler le fait que
les conseils de discipline se réunissent
de manière très importante et je ne
mentionne pas les exclusions temporaires
et autres décisions rendues les élèves
lorsqu'ils sont par obligation de
scolarisation donc ne les élèves sont
évidemment transférés vers un autre
collège un autre établissement avec
suivi et
depuis quelques années on a
le cas de d'élèves poly exclus c'est à
dire des élèves qui se promènent si je
puis dire d'un établissement à l'autre
et qui ne reste jamais très longtemps
compte tenu de leur comportement alors
il est nous avons développé à
l'éducation nationale ce que nous
appelons des classes relais avec j'ai eu
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de voir cela
récemment dans l'Académie de Besançon où
on essaie d'interrompre ce cycle
infernal si j'ose dire d'exclusion à
répétition et d'élèves qui par leur
comportement d'ailleurs perturbent
toutes les communautés
éducatives ou scolaires dans lesquelles
ils sont et donc nous devons porter une
attention particulière à ses élèves
polyexclus qui cumulent souvent
d'ailleurs je note au passage un certain
nombre de difficultés les enfants placés
des élèves avec des difficultés
sociale qui se sont accumulées et dont
nous devons nous occuper aussi bien que
possible
aucun doute là-dessus
madame la alors attendez je
c'était madame la sénatrice brûlant
peut-être oui qui vous posiez madame la
sénatrice pardon une question
à propos des liens avec les RT oui ils
se font au niveau des dazaines ce sont
les les directions académiques qui
entretiennent des liens avec les
RT les services de police et de
gendarmerie en règle générale et j'ai
souvenir je me tourne vers mes voisins
que il y a des demandes d'habilitation
défense qui avait été faite et accordée
donc tous les dazen et leurs adjoints
ainsi que les réacteurs alors directeur
de cabinet je suppose
bénéficie d'une habilitation défense ce
qui leur permet d'avoir accès à des
informations de nature très
confidentielle
à propos des de la veille sur les
réseaux sociaux cela dépend des
académies et de la taille des académies
très très clairement ici au ministère
nous avons du monde à la fois du côté de
la direction de la communication la
delcom et puis du côté de la de la du
haut fonctionnaire et du et du cmva mais
à l'évidence et je pourrais si vous le
souhaitez vous donner des précisions
écrites là-dessus parce que je n'ai pas
en tête le nombre de personnes dans
chaque académie mais c'est variables
selon le selon la taille
et selon leur
voilà leur
ressources humaines en règle en règle
générale mesdames la sénatrice Mercier
vous avez fait allusion à des séries de
comportements inadéquats alors la règle
c'est bien sûr que le même comportement
enfin la même le même acte ne peut pas
être jugé deux fois mais je termine mon
propos
attendez si je peux me permettre madame
la sénatrice si l'acte se répète deux
fois
alors il peut être sanctionné deux fois
donc vous avez peut-être en tête un
exemple
spécifique et donc je changerai avec
vous peut-être
une autre fois mais il est évident que
la règle c'est que le même acte
illégal ou en tout cas problématique qui
se répète peut-être
sanctionner plusieurs fois
y compris s'il est exactement identique
madame la sénatrice voulait et pironie
je vous m'inviter
vous m'invitez au dialogue sur le sujet
sachez que je suis un homme de dialogue
et que je ne le refuse jamais et j'ai pu
échanger du reste avec des députés qui
ont constitué un groupe de travail sur
cette question et je me suis entretenu à
plusieurs reprises avec eux et je serai
heureux d'ailleurs de d'échanger avec
vous sur sur ce sujet je n'ai aucune
difficulté à à l'échange y compris sur
sur la question des uniformes vous avez
fait allusion au passage à la question
du sentiment d'appartenance c'est juste
d'ailleurs dans les études dont nous
disposons il y a quelques études
internationales dont nous disposons le
seul élément probant justement c'est le
sentiment d'appartenance donc vous
faites bien de le signaler parce que les
autres éléments eux
sont beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
évanescents mais je suis à votre
disposition pour échanger sur le sujet
si vous le souhaitez madame la sénatrice
de la pauvreté votre question est je la
trouve très intéressante et je ne suis
pas sûr de pouvoir y répondre
convenablement celle de la d'une lecture
géographique et sociologique
à laquelle vous nous invitez
je vais regarder cela parce que je n'ai
pas vu de de
donner qui permettrait
d'établir un profil ou des profils en
quelque sorte sociologique particulier
des des situations de de violence ou de
menaces
celle dont on parle en tout cas
je vais regarder cela et je reviendrai
vers vous par écrit si vous me le
permettez quant à la question des
professeurs moins expérimentés dans les
établissements difficiles alors elle est
alors c'est vrai que si nous ne
comptions que sur des professeurs
volontaires dans les établissements
difficiles on aurait du mal à avoir tous
les professeurs dont nous avons besoin
il faut quand même le reconnaître face à
cela il y a quand même des incitations
qui sont des incitations par exemple en
éducation prioritaire de prime qui sont
des primes tout de même substantielles
pour les enseignants on parle en rêve
plus de primes qui dépassent 5000 euros
par an ça n'est pas rien j'ajoute à cela
d'ailleurs
un dispositif qui s'est mis en place
récemment et donc on en a pas encore
d'effet mesurables pour le département
de la Seine-Saint-Denis
prime je crois alors je ne veux pas dire
d'erreur mais je crois qu'elle était de
10.000 euros
[Musique]
possible mais si les filles ont un
enseignement très différent de celui des
garçons par exemple un enseignement
scientifique d'un côté et puis un
enseignement
relevant d'autres choses de l'autre
cela se fait d'ailleurs en lien avec les
préfectures et après mise en demeure
nous pouvons fermer les établissements
il y a d'ailleurs dans chaque
département au niveau des dazaines il y
a de mémoire un inspecteur qui est en
charge de des écoles hors contrat
école dont les effectifs sont faibles
mais en croissance en croissance légère
tout de même et donc nous nous regardons
cela elles ne sont pas du tout en dehors
de notre de notre la décision de
fermeture est prise par le préfet n'est
pas prise par les services de
l'éducation nationale mais nous
travaillons en lien avec les préfectures
j'ai pu voir d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'alerte sur un certain nombre de
d'établissement hors contrat monsieur le
Président
alors pardon j'avais
sauté une une petite fiche madame la
sénatrice bourra
votre question sur les de fonds sur le
pourquoi des parents qui contestent
m'invite au fond à une remarque
peut-être un peu plus générale qui est
celle de la contestation de l'autorité
de l'autorité du savoir et nous savons
que un certain nombre de professions
font face à des formes de contestation
qu'elle n'avait pas auparavant je pense
par exemple au médecin dans les hôpitaux
ou même dans les cabinets en ville qui
peuvent avoir des relations tendues avec
des patients qu'il n'avaient pas
auparavant une contestation de
l'autorité du savoir au fond qui
va bien au de l'éducation nationale et
donc je vous rejoins sur le fait que
nous avons besoin de réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'enseignant l'autorité du
professeur j'aime à dire du reste que au
fond la finalité de l'école c'est
l'éducation et c'est ce sont les
apprentissages des élèves et donc leur
réussite mais ce qui est au centre de
l'école c'est peut-être moins ce sont
peut-être moins les élèves comme on l'a
dit souvent que le savoir ce qui est au
centre de l'école ce sont les savoirs et
donc celles et ceux qui transmettent des
savoirs et donc je j'accorde une place
particulière et centrale au professeur
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mais
j'avoue que cela va au-delà de mes
fonctions et que cela concerne au fond
l'ensemble de notre société quelle place
souhaitons nous collectivement
professeur et de cette de la réponse que
nous ferons dépend en partie l'avenir de
l'éducation nationale nous avons besoin
de revaloriser la profession de
professeurs et nous le faisons par des
augmentations de rémunération à partir
de la rentrée mais nous avons aussi
besoin d'une revalorisation morale et
symbolique des professeurs et des
savoirs
qu'il qu'il transmettent aux élèves et
qui ne saurait être contestés moqué
remis en cause par je ne sais quelle
information glaner sur internet par
exemple ou tout autre moyen et donc nous
avons à valoriser et à revaloriser la
place
et le respect qui est dû au professeur
ça j'en suis absolument persuadé
monsieur le sénateur pied-noir à propos
des conseils de discipline et votre ce
point j'indiquais les chiffres qui sont
des chiffres tout de même
impressionnants j'ajoute à ce que je
disais précédemment que dans le cas où
un conseil de discipline se tiendrait
dans un contexte
complexe ou des pressions pourraient se
faire sentir sur les membres du Conseil
du discipline ou le chef d'établissement
la circulaire de novembre dernier
précisait que le conseil de discipline
peut être en quelque sorte dépaysé
peut-être déplacé géographiquement pour
échapper à une situation qui risquerait
d'entraver la sérénité et la liberté du
conseil de discipline donc nous sommes
aussi attentifs aux conditions par
lesquelles le conseil du discipline peut
se réunir mais les chiffres sont là pour
montrer que les conseils de discipline
malheureusement je ne je ne m'en réjouis
pas au fond mais que les conseils de
discipline se réunissent et se
réunissent de façon tout à fait
fréquentes et ordinaire je terminerai
monsieur le Président par les questions
que vous posiez alors je ne suis pas au
courant de mes je vais regarder je me
permettrai de vous répondre par écrit à
propos de fait disons de contestation
relative à des formations
proposées à des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale formation de
laïcité ou faisait allusion à des faits
qui sont intervenus au début 2022 et
dont je me souviens je n'ai pas entendu
parler d'autres choses mais je
j'ai prêté serment et donc je ne veux
pas dire de choses qui ne correspondrait
pas à la réalité donc je vous répondrai
par écrit quant au Conseil supérieur des
programmes il a toute liberté bien sûr
pour établir les programmes et
heureusement d'ailleurs vous savez que
il y a des il y a des parlementaires
parmi les membres du Conseil supérieur
des programmes qui sont là aussi pour
attester de la de la liberté de ce
conseil et il serait proprement
inadmissible que ce conseil en vienne à
se censurer ou ou s'auto-censurer
ensuite il s'agit de regarder
l'application des programmes ça n'est
pas le rôle du Conseil supérieur des
programmes c'est le rôle de l'inspection
générale par exemple qui va regarder les
écarts entre les programmes et puis sur
le papier si je puis dire et puis
là la réalité
mettez-moi un mot sur À propos du
Conseil supérieur des programmes le fait
que j'ai que j'ai saisi son président
récemment à propos de la réforme de
l'enseignement moral et civique puisque
j'ai annoncé pour le collège le
doublement des heures consacrées à
l'enseignement moral et civique de 18 à
36 heures par an
et que cela s'accompagnait également
d'une refonte du programme de
l'enseignement moral et civique qui a un
peu vieilli pour toutes sortes de
raisons et donc le Conseil supérieur des
programmes c'est saisi d'une réforme de
l'enseignement moral et civique dont
nous avons peut-être encore plus besoin
que que d'habitude dont nous avons
besoin littéralement
la proposition que vous faites à propos
du 16 octobre donc de commémoration
de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty alors je
n'étais je ne me souvenais pas oui c'est
le Conseil des Sages de cette
proposition il y a bien sûr le 16
octobre chaque année une commémoration
qui est organisée dans tous les
établissements scolaires qui peut
prendre d'ailleurs plusieurs formes mais
cette commémoration et
comment dirais-je respecter je ne sache
pas qu'elle prenne la forme qu'a proposé
le Conseil des Sages j'ajoute à cela le
fait que outre le 16 octobre nous avons
le neuf décembre qui est la Journée
annuelle de la laïcité et le 9 décembre
et l'occasion
moins de commémorer l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty que d'insister sur les
principes de la ïcité
merci monsieur le ministre il n'y a pas
d'autres questions on va clôturer notre
audition vous remerciant bien entendu et
je syndicat de nos collègues que la
prochaine audition aura lieu la semaine
prochaine ça reste à déterminer
exactement le créneau mais avec Sylvie
Retailleau ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche merci bonne
fin d'après-midi merci monsieur le
ministre et pour nous sera demain matin
8h30 merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs